Sam I'm just going to listen to baby's
heart rate is that okay Belinda and Rita
are in their last year as student
midwives soon they'll be doing this
every day for real so baby's nice and
happy okay joining a Health Service
under pressure and understaffed with
over a hundred and ten thousand NHS job
vacancies this is when we need to look
to the government to increase
apprenticeship opportunities and to
increase the opportunity for people to
train and join the NHS the government's
long awaited 15-year NHS Workforce plan
is expected to double medical school and
nursing training places
eight months of consecutive strikes over
pay have resulted in more than 650
000 routine operations and appointments
being canceled those on the picket line
say that care is already under threat
due to poor working conditions and staff
shortages
this Workforce plan has been repeatedly
delayed and that's caused real
frustration for NHS trust leaders now at
last they'll have some direction and
some reassurance but this is a long-term
project and not a short-term fix for the
problems that exist right now
come on come here Mika and I was
basically told that I'd have a few
months to live
and that was six months ago Sue has a
blocked artery and lives with the risk
of suffering a stroke
she has had eight potentially
life-saving operations delayed so far
this year can't go anywhere do anything
and at any moment I could fad on the
floor
and
as there is a Lifeline an opportunity of
an operation
it's very frustrating ventilate
an aging population suffering from more
complex illnesses will need a reliable
modern and well staffed Health Service
the next generation of NHS workers are
hoping they can play their part
oh she's Josh is Sky News in Kent